economic stimulus the world can invest
funding the act accelerator will cost a
tiny fraction in comparison
to the alternative where economies
retract further
and require continued physical stimulus
packages before spending another
10 trillion us dollars on the
consequences of the next wave
we estimate that the world will need to
spend
at least 100 billion us dollars on new
tools
especially any new vaccines that are
developed
the first and most immediate need is
31.3 billion as dollars for the act
accelerator the act accelerator is the
only
up and running global initiative
that brings together all the global
research and development
manufacturing regulatory purchasing and
procurement needed
for all the tools required to end the
pandemic
picking individual winners is an
expensive risky gamble
the act accelerator enables governments
to spread
the risk and share reward
in particular
majority of vaccines in early
development failed
multiple vaccine candidates
when a successful new vaccine is found
there will be greater demand
than there is
fund and competition for supply is
already creating vaccine nationalism
and risk of price gouging
alone the best solution for everyone is
a blend of development assistance
finance packages
to fund this and this
and the pandemic
dependent
the best chance to be successful is
always do it together
i thank you
thank you very much dr ted ross i'll now
open the floor to questions from
journalists
but before that i'd like to remind you
that if you want to ask a question you
must use the raise your hand icon
even if you've submitted the question
beforehand and i'll also apologize to
you
now to those who miss out we've got a
lot of people online
so please restrict your questions to one
question
i know it's a really complex subject but
please
try to just ask the one question we've
got a lot of very strong science and
health journalists on the line
and we'll start with helen branswell
from stat news helen could you unmute
yourself
and ask your question
hi hi all thank you very much for taking
my question
i've asked before and i'm gonna ask it
again one of these
times the answer might be different is
there any evidence
yet of um you know confirmed reinfection
of cases of people who had earlier had
infection
and have had a second subsequent
infection
hi helen uh thanks for the question it's
a it's a timely one i think this is on
the minds of many individuals
um there are some examples of countries
that have suggested that an
an individual may have been re-infected
um there's still not still not confirmed
um what we need to be able to do is to
look
at a few things one is the testing
that's been done in an individual and
how long that individual tests positive
because some people can can have pcr
positivity for
many weeks not just days but many weeks
and it doesn't necessarily mean that
they are infectious for that long
um there are some examples of
individuals who have had
tested pcr positive and then after
several days several weeks
have tested after testing negative have
tested positive again we've had some
examples in korea
and that was not an example of
reinfection um there is
what we are trying to do in the
instances where there may be an
individual um that tests positive again
we need to look at a few things one is
how the tests were collected what
samples were collected the tests that
were used to see if there are any issues
of false
positivity or false negativity and what
we ideally would like is to look at
sequencing
if the virus can be isolated and
sequencing can be done
the third thing that we're looking at is
the immune response
that an individual has after infection
you've heard us talk about this quite a
lot
there's a lot that we're still learning
we expect that individuals who are
infected with the sars kobe 2 virus
develop an immune response um we don't
know for how long
that immune response lasts we don't know
how strong it is or how long it lasts
and that is something that is currently
actively under development and of course
somebody will have protection from
reinfection
while they have those have those uh
antibodies
um so it's a long-winded answer to say
we don't know yet
um but uh we are actively following up
any examples
um where this may be suggested
thanks very much dr van kerkov the next
question comes from
antonio brodo from the spanish newswire
fa
antonio could you unmute yourself and
ask your question
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
the questions about the russian vaccine
so thank you very much this is bruce
elward who's heading up the hub for the
actic
accelerator as everyone on the call is
aware
we have now dozens and dozens indeed
a hundred or well over 170 vaccine
candidates that are under evaluation
around the world at different stages
26 of those have been in clinical trial
one of which as
uh people on the skull will be aware was
the russian vaccine
and it was not one of the vaccines that
are in the kovacs
portfolio i think there was a specific
question about the nine that are in the
portfolio
it does not include that vaccine or
those vaccines
um and in terms i think there was a
specific question about
whether or not we would see uh the whole
[Music]
expanded use of that we don't have
sufficient information at this point to
make a judgment on that and we're
currently in conversation with russia to
get additional information understand
the status of that product the trials
that have been undertaken
and then what the next steps might be
add anything sorry dr swaminathan on the
line do you want to add anything
no doctor
no i think that's fine uh margaret
that's fine i don't want to happen
thank you so much
the next question goes to kai kupashmit
from
science kai could you unmute yourself
and go ahead
yes thanks for taking my question so
very very big picture question i'm i'm
curious
so you know following the the wh o
numbers um on code 19
you can kind of see that globally the
numbers are leveling off now i'm aware
that this is you know as a pandemic this
is a lot of different
outbreaks you know all going on at the
same time each with its own dynamic
i'm just curious where they can speak a
little bit to
you know the global picture at the
moment how do you see it do you expect
the numbers globally to to kind of stay
at this
spot or even go down what's the dynamic
if you take the very big picture of you
at the moment
i think i can uh start with uh maria
bruce
others may may wish to win i think
yes you mean you are right that the
numbers vary from week to week from
month to month from geography to
geography
but i think what we have to keep in mind
is a very small proportion
of the world's population have actually
got been exposed to this virus and have
developed an infection
and have developed an immunologic memory
to the virus so this virus is a long way
to burn
if we allow it it may move
in certain populations more efficiently
depending on
behavior it may move in in certain
populations depending on whether people
are spending more time inside or outside
it may return
colder periods it may it may do many
things
but the one thing i think we have to
remember is
most people the vast majority of people
remain susceptible to this infection
countries i think in terms of the
overall global picture there are still a
number of countries
that are very much dealing with
extensive uncontrolled
community transmission with all of the
consequences that go with that
pressure on the health system
preventable debts
and uh and all of the socioeconomic
damage that caused
with that having to take very very
strong measures to try and control the
disease
there is a number of other countries at
the other end of the spectrum who have
previously brought the disease under
control but are now experiencing
spikes in the numbers of cases mainly
related to clusters
of infection around particular events
around particular contexts
around crowds around gatherings and
other things
and they're struggling obviously to
bring those clusters under control
in order to prevent community
transmission reigniting and i think
that's probably the key
issue here once you get community
transmission under control
and you get back to clusters or sporadic
cases you have to try and keep it there
because if you allow if you take
pressure off this virus
it will slip back towards community
transmission and once community
transmission takes off
establishes itself and becomes intense
than you of
all the consequences of the health
system under pressure death rates rising
hospitalizations rising
so the key objective for us all
is to try and suppress infection to a
point where we have control at community
level
and then risk manage our way through
this and we have to make some
difficult trade-offs opening schools
versus uh crowded gathering places we
need to make choices
and some of those choices are not easy
they
i think that's going to be the struggle
over the coming months making good
choices
governments making good choices
communities making good choices
and individuals making good choices and
that requires good information
that requires good data that requires
knowledge
and being able to act dg said it in the
speech he said we have the tools we have
a number of tools that we know that work
we need to continue to apply them
and we need to as he has alluded to and
bruce as well
we need to accelerate the development of
vaccines and we need to be able to pay
for a massive expansion
in our capacity to deliver vaccines to
everyone that needs them but
i would characterize the global
situation now yes we've seen a
plateauing of numbers kai and i know you
track that uh
you track that every day but this is
like the cascades of a waterfall you can
go down one level and you think you're
in calm water and you go over the next
level and you're in a waterfall again
so i do think we need to be very very
careful
can waters do not mean the storm is over
we may just be in the eye of the storm
and we don't know it so i think absolute
vigilance now
and those countries that have made
progress please retain that progress
you will lose that progress if you were
lent if you become complacent
those countries that are in community
transmission the dg keeps saying it
there is always time to turn it around
some of the countries now that have the
best
numbers are countries that had terrible
outbreaks
only a few months ago look at italy look
what italy has achieved
in terms of its ability to control this
disease it is never too late
to put this virus under pressure so
those countries
that are making have made progress give
us hope but those countries who have
made progress
need to remain vigilant
i just i mean we've said it many times
but the trajectory of this pandemic
in every country is in our hands it
remains
in our hands and i think that we need to
say that as much as we possibly can
because
there is hope of countries that have
been in terrible situations as mike
um and the trajectory is in our hands
and it depends on the actions of
countries it depends on the actions of
governments
communities of individuals there are
many situations where we have choices
where we can
reduce our risk of exposure and it is
really really critical
that as societies open up that we
minimize
the infections the number of people that
get infected even among people who are
at a lower risk
of developing severe diseases they may
also pass the virus
to somebody else who may be of a
vulnerable category who could develop a
severe disease
need hospitalization and die and i think
that's really really important
and i think what we're learning seven
months in is that the actions that need
to be taken
at the different levels to suppress
transmission to reduce mortality
now with the tools we have now are
fairly clear
it's the implementation that is
incredibly difficult
and the consistency and the vigilance
and the focus to do this having clear
plans
but localized adapted implementation
is really really difficult um and to
have this done at the scale that's
necessary depending on the intensity
um and what we're seeing for countries
that are opening up that are seeing
these clusters
really quick action to stamp out and put
out those individual fires
where those outbreaks are happening is
proving successful
so as an individual avoid the crowded
places where a mask where
appropriate listen to your governments
if you're asked to stay home please do
so
because there are many frontline workers
essential workers who are out there who
are doing
incredibly hard work that are keeping
people alive everybody has a role to
play
and we will say this over and over and
over again
that we have control we have power that
we can play a role in this and really do
everything we can to prevent
ourselves getting infected
thank you very much doctors ryan and dr
van kempen i'd also remind you we've as
i said we've got a wealth of
expertise in this room and on the line i
mentioned dr
swaminathan i we also have dr hanan
who can talk about the therapeutics arm
of the act accelerator
among many other topics we also have dr
edward kelly
who can talk about the health systems
arm of the act accelerator
so you've got a great opportunity here
today
the next question goes to simon attaba
from today news africa
simon please unmute yourself and go
ahead
thank you for taking my question this is
simon a deba from today news africa in
washington d.c
it's been six months since the first
confirmed case of
kovite 19 was recorded in africa between
then and now more than a million
cases have been recorded and over 24
000 people have died however
these cases are mainly concentrated
within five countries in africa
south africa egypt nigeria ghana and
algeria
i was wondering do we know exactly why
some countries are affected more than
others
and what are other countries doing
right that this that these five
countries are not doing
thank you
thank you
and if you look at those those are very
highly popular so i think egypt and
nigeria and south africa are the most
populous countries in africa so yes
we would expect the most cases to be in
those countries
some other factors south africa would
have imported disease some
much earlier than other countries quite
early in the course of this dynamic
pandemic has had longer to generate its
its epidemic curve in that situation
equally
nigeria as well so some of these
countries are highly connected if you
look at these countries
they're very connected through uh direct
airline routes and others
to europe and they may have important
diseases earlier they also have a lot of
family and other links
with other countries so there may be
elements of how the disease and when it
was introduced into
those countries also i would argue that
paradoxically these five countries
actually have relatively strong
public health systems they have good
surveillance systems they have good
national labs and they may actually
be detecting more cases than some other
countries so
the absence of evidence is not
evidence of absence and in this case i
think
countries with stronger public health
laboratory systems
more quickly so equally though on the
other side there are risk factors
associated with these countries and that
is large
dense urban populations in nigeria
in south africa in egypt and therefore
on the other side of it
there are pockets of poverty and
large pockets of urban poverty in which
this disease
can spread much more much more easily so
i'd say there are factors in two
directions
uh simon these countries are more at
risk these countries have larger
populations
these countries have strong surveillance
capacity
to detect but also there are real
reasons why these countries
are at higher risk given their
population distribution and their dense
very urban
surveillance strategies
it isn't evenly distributed throughout
the entire month
um and so i think i think there may be
unrecognized cases that way yeah
there's also demographic differences
where you have younger populations
younger than some
countries perhaps in europe in north
america and you have different
prevalences
of underlying conditions which put
people who are infected with the cyrus
virus at a higher risk of developing
severe disease therefore
possibly being detected by the health
system and i
think there's a number of factors there
and i think in the beginning of this
pandemic we were asked this question
a lot why aren't we seeing so many cases
in this country
so it's a combination i think one of the
things that i find
quite interesting are the results from
the early epidemiologic studies
um there's a variety of them a large
number of them that are happening across
the globe
at present and some of the early results
in africa are suggesting that there are
people who have detected antibodies
meaning that they have been infected
but they were unrecognized by the
current system
and so i think we also need to look at
that data
and perhaps they didn't develop a severe
disease they didn't develop a disease
so as mike has said it's a number of
factors
thank you very much dr brian and dr van
kerkov the next question
is from bianca rottier from
globo brazil uh bianca can you unmute
yourself and ask your questions
a lot margaret for taking my question
here
yeah bianca i'm correspondent in
switzerland for global news and global
the largest city network in brazil and
china my question is about um china that
announced
today that the chicken wings imported
from brazil tested positive for coffee
19.
so what should be done in a situation
like these can we get infected by the
virus
from food including frozen food what are
the risks what are the recommendations
for
consumers people that are the people
that work
in transportation of food and also in
production and packaging
and of course to companies and
governments as well
thanks a lot so thanks for the question
so yes um you know we are aware of the
reports of
these tests um what we understand
um is that china is testing on packaging
they're looking for the virus um
they've tested a few hundred thousand
samples um
packaging and have found very very few
less than 10.
positive in doing that we have issued
guidance
um with fao on food handlers
and working with working with frozen
foods working with live foods to keep
people safe in their working environment
we know that the virus can be
can remain on surfaces for some time but
the virus can be inactivated on your
hands
if you wash your hands or use alcohol
based rub and there's way and if the
virus is
actually in the future and we have no
so we'd have issued
people are already scared enough
[Music]
like this and it's important that we
don't discount scientific evidence where
we find it
but it's also important that people can
go about their daily lives
without fear people should not fear food
or food packaging or
processing or delivery of food food is
very important and i would
i would think that we would
create an impression that there's a
problem
there is no evidence that food or the
food chain
is participating in transmission of this
virus
people should feel comfortable and feel
safe
there are many other reasons why we need
to protect and we need to cook our food
properly and there are many other
contaminants of food that occurs
but i think we should not be replacing
as
but there are many other reasons
and many many people work very very hard
goes to michael from cnn michael can you
unmute yourself and ask your question
uh good afternoon from ottawa this is
michael basic here i'm a contributor to
cnn opinion
um there's been a lot of talk thank you
for taking my question there's been a
lot of talk about the expected demand
for the new vaccine but
as you know antibacters have taken to
social media in a big way
in fact i'd say there's almost a virus
of disinformation out there about the
future
vaccine and uh according to a cnn poll
in may
and this is quite shocking about
one-third of americans said they would
not get vaccinated against coronavirus
even if it were widely available and low
cost
um and then just quickly i interviewed
uh just now the head of rotary
international john
alcorn and he said one of the end games
of covet crisis will be vaccinations and
that there will be resistance
however there's a lot to learn from
polio in terms of how to overcome the
resistance so my question is
what needs to be done have governments
underestimated the
degree of resistance and is it too late
to counter that effectively
thank you
thank you for the question because it's
absolutely important
that there's work on both sides on the
vaccine acceptance
and also on the vaccine hesitancy and
wgo takes this
extremely serious because as you
mentioned there are there are already
problems with routine vaccination
and we see that the problems are related
either to mistrust on institutions or on
scientific information
but also because of the very rapid
access to incorrect information that
happens
uh through social media and so on so
double joe has been working
in the past years and it's intensifying
his work
with the social medias platforms to
ensure that
there is early detection of incorrect
information and there are also people
looking for information that they have
access to
the the right sites that provide solid
and scientific based information on
vaccines but this is
absolutely uh uh a work stream that was
taken very seriously thinking that
we will need to have a rapid uptake
in many countries as vaccines become
available
if i could just add some things right
now about this issue
um in addition to what angela just said
is that
we're engaging with a lot of different
little steps of not being skipped
in terms of safety and also to
understand
acceptance and demand and so we're
working with different groups to work on
communication packages
listening so this
groups that are working with us civil
society individuals
that most people want access to a safety
so there's a lot of different avenues
that we are pursuing
but really trying to increase vaccine
understanding acceptance and demand is
something
very very specific and we're listening
and we're learning and we're developing
those kids
and maybe
these vaccines can be introduced in the
most successful way
there are reasons for vaccine hesitancy
there are reasons for
lack of acceptance of vaccines and they
range from specific fears about the
vaccine to distrust
there are many different reasons and
bruce
has vast years of experience in polio
overcoming
issues and misunderstandings and
misinformation
myself think about congo in eastern
congo in the last year and a half
we were using an investigational news
vaccine brand new vaccine
in a population in the middle of a
highly conflictual situation with a very
disruptive society
and through the work that we
their acceptance but it's also a two-way
street there must be a dialogue
people need to be allowed to have a
conversation about brexit
and have a proper conversation it's not
a one-way street
it's not about shoving things down
people it's about having a proper
discussion
good information a good discussion on
this and people will make up their own
minds and i think science
and government have a job to do that is
to make the case
i think communities and people have a
job
and michael thank you for the uh point i
don't want to belabor it because others
have covered the big points but
um first no one's underestimating this
and one of the ways and things that
we're doing to address it also
is to make sure that we're putting
together an integrated package of tools
and that's what the act accelerator is
all about
we all want a silver bullet but we want
to make sure we have multiple ones we
need
better faster diagnostics we need
therapeutics we need the vaccines
not everyone may use a vaccine it may
not work in everyone so we need the
other tools and as mike has been
emphasizing
we need those tools now especially the
diagnostics to be able to get the
massive step change
in terms of the coverage of folks who
number one know their status whether or
not they have the disease
and number two whether or not they're
still shedding and they're isolated
properly
so that's the reason and again one more
of the arguments as we do all these
pieces
to work now and to be prepared
but it's another thing to emphasize
one of the key things we're trying to do
with the accelerator is to move
and parallel things that we would
normally do in sequence normally
we do the research and development and
then we do the manufacturing and the
pre-qualification then we work on the
delivery issues
but in this again i think you refer to
it we're trying to do
all of those almost in parallel that's
why we need the money
up front that's how we're going to be
successful
if we do all the work on the r d we
don't have the resources to do this
community preparedness work exactly as
you're speaking to
we won't be as successful as we want to
be won't get the coverage that we need
my question is still about the vaccine
so dumbbell issue has always been
promoting the equal distribution of
vaccines
so now i want to ask how many countries
now have
publicly declared that if they have an
effective vaccine against kobe 19
being developed and they will treat it
as a public good for the world
and what are the positions of the major
countries that have
now have most developments in the
vaccine research
i think this is a question for dr mary
angela again
thank you for the question that's a very
hard discussion at the moment
because we are talking about a vaccine
a safe and effective vaccine being a
public health good
and we are talking about ensuring that
there is equitable access to the
technologies that are developed
and that they reach all countries that
they benefit
populations in all countries not only a
high-income country so
so this is a and where we we're going
through a moment where
we see that some countries are are are
doing bilateral agreements with
companies but at the same time
we have a global movement
we are working together and
international organizations wgo with the
vax and alliance
government and working together
discussing the member states the
organization of a global facility and
this this global facility
will be a poor mechanism to to procure
invest in vaccine candidates and ensure
that countries who are participating
it's open to all countries
will have access to the vaccines once
they are
they they prove to be safe and effective
so far we have a 167 countries already
engaged in this process
so i think it's uh it's very reassuring
that we have such a
global commitment towards
ensuring that there is once a technology
is available
that there would be a a commitment to
ensure that equitable access on a timely
fashion that all countries which
are reached by the vaccines
thank you very much dr marie angela and
we'll now move to the next question
we've only got time for a couple more
questions because we've got a heart stop
at 6
30. the next question goes to john
miller from reuters
the reuters hi thanks very much
um as we look around the world we see a
lot of
unilateral deals between companies and
countries for vaccines
and we heard earlier this week dr tedros
talking about uh
only being about ten percent of the way
towards the uh the act accelerator goal
including the the kovacs component of
that and i'm wondering do you have
concern that these unilateral deals
whether it's between switzerland and a
company or the u.s or europe
that they are competing with efforts on
a multilateral level
to address this problem and perhaps in a
more comprehensive way
and it relates a little bit to the
question that we just heard
you know it's an interesting situation
we're in when we first started
talking about vaccines of course against
this disease
everybody was quick to say it's so
important that we have
enough of these products we equity
distribute these products but then of
course we've seen
um a lot as as you just mentioned of
countries
um now moving forward on bilateral deals
we call them
uh and or multilateral deals to try and
secure
access for their populations and the
motivation behind that at a certain
level of course
they can be understood but what's
interesting now it's a little bit the
point that marie angela just spoke to is
over the last couple of months there's
been an increasing
recognition among countries that they
it is not enough to vaccinate their own
uh
populations and they're also recognizing
that they don't
need to vaccinate their whole
populations immediately
to get the biggest bang potentially from
these vaccines
and what we're seeing more and more is
that even
in fact just over the last few days even
weeks we're seeing
countries that have set bilateral and
multilateral deals
coming to us and saying look how do we
work with you to make sure
that we're part of a solution that
ensures that this
rolls out simultaneously to the world
like the director general said
there's self-interest in this as well as
the moral case for it because
there's a recognition we cannot get the
global economies moving again
we cannot get travel trade
transportation the world is just too
interlinked and what we've got to do is
get pressure off the health systems
because that's been what the real
drag on the economies have been and the
course of doing that will save lives
and we can do that again a little like
mariangela
mentioned by vaccinating a proportion of
the global population together
much more effectively than if we were to
try and do
pockets of it you know completely one at
a time
and it's it's it's been encouraging and
just striking
how many countries that are doing deals
and on the other hand
remember as countries are making deals
and the rest they're sending very loud
messages that they want these vaccines
and then manufacturers have a whole new
confidence that they need to expand
their capacities they need to produce
more of these products produce more of
it at risk
so the key thing at this point is how do
we harness
all of those investments into a global
solution and that's what the director
general was speaking about
it's the time now that we've got we have
hard evidence
that the best solution is to roll this
out simultaneously globally
every economy is interlinked today it
just will not work
otherwise and as we as we move toward
that
now it's the trying to work out okay the
nuts and bolts if you've
bought a lot of vaccine over there how
do we work with you to make sure
that that can be part of a global
solution and that's really where we are
and remember we have some time to sort
this out um we hear a lot of
panic about buying and deals etc but we
have a couple of months to work together
as a global community
to find the solution to this so we roll
these out in the way that's going to be
most effective
so a global solution where we're all
pooling our risks cooling our
procurement would be the
ideal if we do separate deals then it is
how do we coordinate these
so that we don't prejudice any part of
the world
in a way that's ultimately going to be
detrimental to everyone
even those who work to try and vaccinate
their own populations completely first
so yeah perhaps i'll leave it at that
but marie angela you've been a
a big piece of this work
i think the the fact that
if you are betting in one or two
candidates
we have around 200 vaccine candidates at
the moment
so what's your best bet we don't have
any
any any of the vac the vaccine
candidates has
finished the clinical trials yet
so we don't know which one will be the
front which one will actually
prove to be safe and effective so we are
encouraging countries to join a global
facility because
we will have access to more candidates
and you have a better chance
to actually have concrete access be able
to procure
one of the successful candidates i think
this is the main
issue sorry just going to come back on
it for one second because
again the director general in his
comments he mentioned some numbers
that are so staggering right 10 trillion
dollars
in global stimulus financing fiscal
stimulus financing
to deal with the consequences of this
disease not even the causes
and the kind of numbers that we're
talking about to try and roll out a
global solution are a fraction
of that so again uh coming to the points
that we were discussing earlier
countries are recognizing that they're
recognizing that
if we don't get a global solution
there's going to be waves of global
fiscal stimulus financing needed to try
and
get out of this crisis similar to what
would happen with the global financial
crisis
and that's a situation that nobody wants
to be in so i think all of these factors
are coming together i'm sorry
i can't remember the name of ask the
question i apologize but um
it's a fantastic question we have an
opportunity we have a window
and so now it's aligning all of these
deals so that they
roll out with the right timing it's not
who bought the vaccine almost it's how
they use that vaccine in a globally
coordinated manner
for a global solution to a global crisis
thank you so much dr elwood and dr dr
chamel for those fantastic answers
we're really running out of time so last
question we go to
north africa to morocco and the question
is
from hassan abdellah from moroccan news
uh please unmute yourself and ask your
questions
i think this question will be for dr
ryan
the country should be doing about okay
yeah we'll
uh just uh trying to get the exact
numbers
uh sorry forgive me for morocco maybe
maria you can start
yes
maybe two um and the number of this i
think is
556. and
um i think if you
see the situation it's not the number of
cases but
the trend is on the increase in the
number of cases
um i think morocco should uh
do do more especially to
reverse
compared to many countries actually if
you see the
number of this it's
situation is very even throughout the
country so
they can focus where the concentration
of cases
is and where especially
but in the last august the week of
august three is
the highest since the
supplement as switches well the numbers
for example across
the eastern mediterranean north africa
and middle east
numbers in places like saudi arabia
pakistan and others
are falling
rapid increases in morocco in lebanon
now unfortunately and that's a big
concern in the aftermath of the
explosion there is
24 hours iraq has the most cases new
cases
reported from the eastern mediterranean
region i believe that's the first time
where iraq
has had the top number of cases for that
region so i think we're seeing a very
dynamic situation
in the region morocco has also had some
previous issues of clusters of
infections and prisons and other places
and again it shows that the difficulty
when you get clusters established
in certain areas and certain groups you
may end up with those clusters extending
into full-blown community transmission
so morocco is not alone in north africa
or in the eastern mediterranean
with an increasing trend of cases as the
dg says
every country now needs to double down
uh examine what it's doing where it's
doing at a national sub-national level
and effectively use the tools that we do
have morocco has
if you go back over the last number of
months
actually morocco had a very very low
level of disease
right the way through the early parts of
this pandemic so there's no question
morocco has the capacity to do that
every country has had to contend with
flare-ups
every country has had to contend with
this disease bouncing back
the question is not does the disease
bounce back the disease bounces back
it happens it's a virus it exploits
weaknesses and gaps
back don't blame others take action
everyone takes action together
in response to a jumping disease then
the disease will
go away it will be pushed away i think
in too many countries
we tend to look for scapegoats we tend
whose fault is it that the disease is
back who made a mistake
in an emergency response there's no time
for that
it's a time for action when the
emergency is over you sit down and then
you say okay
during an emergency we need everyone to
act together and act quickly
i think morocco has demonstrated right
the way through this pandemic its
capacity to keep disease at a low level
morocco needs to get back there again
with many other countries who are in a
very similar
situation
just to mike's point this really comes
back to kai uh
what kai asked earlier about this
leveling of virus that we're seeing
globally
i mean what we're actually seeing and as
mike talks about all the time
is to affect factors the first is
the scale of the susceptibility of the
world
the vast majority of the population in
the world
is susceptible to this disease the
second thing that we're seeing
is the stringency of the application of
control measures is dropping
people are coming closer together as
murray has been talking about
mass rp is always the way that they
should etc
and so any leveling of the disease that
we're looking at
it's just a lulling you into a sense of
false security
get the isolation capacity in place
but the virus is here today which means
we've got to use the tools we have today
or we're going to see these flares just
like um
yeah thank you so much so thank you to
those who have
joined today